you can be better at everything in the
world there's not one thing in the world
that I don't think I can be better at
not one skiing teaching punching eating
there's everything I can be better at I
can't be world class at everything that
is something the world's going to have
to get better at honey you can be
anything you want in the world no honey
you can maximize your natural talent in
every category if you put a lot of work
ethic into it you just might not be
Beyonce and LeBron and that's awesome
but like for example I love basketball I
could be way better I could tomorrow
hire a new shooting coach I could be
better but to what degree but I'm not
going to be in the NBA it's a very
simple sentence dad I'm going to be X
cool anything that isn't physical I
would argue is in play I think it's
remarkable to say you can be anything
you want I think the part that has also
been lost is hard work